.
Ja, Klimawandel,
immer mehr Menschen verstehen,
es ist jetzt allerhöchste Eisenbahn.
Überall fordern
Schüler und Studierende
eine nachhaltigere
Klimaschutzpolitik.
I don't want you to be hopeful,
I want you to panic.
Wir müssen die Erderwärmung
aufhalten, klar. Nur wie?
Nur noch Fahrradfahren,
vegan werden, Bäume pflanzen?
Die schlechte Nachricht ist,
das reicht alles nicht.
Wir brauchen
einen viel größeren Plan.
Die gute Nachricht:
Wir haben den Plan.
Und zwar einen wirklich guten
wissenschaftlichen Plan,
den v.a. die Bundesregierung
dringend hören muss.
Nur leider interessiert sich
kein Politiker für YouTuber,
es sei denn natürlich,
Rezo ist involviert.
Ich brauch deine Hilfe,
kannst du was für mich aufnehmen?
Okay, läuft schon?
- Ja, läuft.
Nice. Hallo, liebe Politiker,
ich bin der mit den blauen Haaren.
Erinnert ihr euch?
Jetzt hört mal der Mai zu,
weil das ist wichtig.
Aber nicht nur Politiker
sollten hier genau zuhören,
jeder einzelne von euch spielt hier
eine sehr wichtige Rolle.
Dazu komme ich auch gleich noch.
Aber holt euch erst mal einen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich,
wir steigen da jetzt zusammen durch.
Freunde der Sonne, holt eure Kalender
und markiert euch den 20.9.,
da passieren nämlich
zwei wichtige Sachen.
1) Der dritte globale Klimastreik
findet statt.
Überall auf der Welt
und in vielen deutschen Städten
werden die Leute
auf die Straße gehen.
2) In Berlin wird sich das
Klimakabinett der Bundesregierung
zusammensetzen, um konkrete
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu beschließen.
Deswegen knöpfen wir uns in diesem
Video die zwei großen Fragen vor.
1) Was kann ich persönlich
gegen den Klimawandel tun?
Und 2) Was kann die Politik
Oder anders gesagt:
Was muss jetzt getan werden?
Wir fangen mit der Politik an,
hier ist das Inhaltsverzeichnis
für dieses Video.
In der Videobeschreibung
findet ihr auch die Timecode-Links.
Aber bitte schaut euch
das ganze Video an,
denn es lohnt sich wirklich, die
verschiedenen Aspekte zu verstehen.
Kapitel 1:
Bis auf ein paar
Wissenschaftsverweigerer
sind sich unsere Politiker einig,
dass man auf die Klimaforscher
hören muss,
und irgendetwas
gegen den Klimawandel tun muss.
Nur wie dieses "irgendetwas"
genau aussieht,
darüber ist man sich nicht einig.
Klima schützen, ja klar,
nur zu welchem Preis?
Geht das auf Kosten
der sozialen Gerechtigkeit,
auf Kosten von Arbeitsplätzen,
auf Kosten der Wirtschaft?
Über diese Abwägung
streitet man sich noch.
Deswegen: Was sagt eigentlich
die Wissenschaft hierzu?
Lars und ich
haben in den letzten Wochen
mit vielen Experten gesprochen,
mit verschiedensten Backgrounds.
Sie waren sich über fünf Sachen
einig. - Jetzt gut zuhören.
Fangen wir von vorne an:
Eins ist klar, wir können es uns
nicht mehr leisten,
so weiterzuleben wie momentan.
I want you to panic.
"Wir können es uns nicht leisten"
ist aber natürlich sehr vage.
Ein CO2-Preis sorgt dafür, dass
wir tatsächlich finanziell sehen,
was wir uns leisten können
und eben auch nicht mehr.
Der CO2-Preis übersetzt
unsere ökologischen Ambitionen.
Wir wollen das Klima schützen,
übersetzt ein CO2-Preis
für einen Konsumenten,
für eine Firma, für eine Bank,
übersetzt das in konkrete
ökonomische Entscheidungen.
Das ist Ottmar Edenhofer,
er ist Wirtschaftsprofessor
und Leiter des Potsdam-Instituts
für Klimafolgenforschung.
Er hat zusammen
mit dem Sachverständigenrat
der Wirtschaftsweisen
der Bundeskanzlerin
dieses Sondergutachten vorgelegt.
Hier wird
wissenschaftlich analysiert,
welche Klimapolitik
jetzt gefragt ist.
Wenn Sie in den Supermarkt gehen
und einkaufen,
Sie können gar nicht überblicken,
was der CO2-Gehalt der Produkte ist.
Es ist unmöglich, Sie können evtl.
bei manchen Produkten sehen,
also Mango an Weihnachten, dass das
vielleicht sehr CO2-intensiv ist.
Aber Sie können das unmöglich
bei allen Produkten sehen.
D.h., wenn wir CO2-Bepreisung hätten,
dann würden die Preise im Supermarkt
auch den CO2-Gehalt reflektieren.
Und dann würden wir an der Kasse
weniger bezahlen,
wenn wir CO2-freundlicher
eingekauft hätten.
Wir übersetzen gewissermaßen
Klimaschädlichkeit in Geld.
Damit wir das konkreter verstehen
und angehen können.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man
einen CO2-Preis einführen kann.
Gehen wir beides kurz durch:
1) Emissionshandel.
Beim Emissionshandel
legt die Regierung
eine gewisse Menge CO2 fest,
die in einem Jahr
ausgestoßen werden darf.
Also ein festes CO2-Budget,
das nicht überschritten werden darf.
Dieses Budget wird dann
aufgeteilt unter den Unternehmen,
die CO2 ausstoßen.
Die müssen nämlich, um das zu tun,
erst mal Ausstoßungsrechte erwerben.
Also Anteile an diesem Budget,
sogenannte Zertifikate.
Emissionshandel heißt das Ganze,
weil diese Zertifikate untereinander
gehandelt werden können.
Wenn ein Unternehmen
erfolgreich CO2 reduziert, so sehr,
dass es weniger CO2 ausstößt,
als es ursprünglich eingekauft hat,
dann kann es die überschüssigen
Zertifikate wieder verkaufen.
Und andersrum, wenn
ein Unternehmen mehr CO2 ausstößt,
als es ursprünglich eingekauft hat,
muss es dafür die zusätzlichen
Zertifikate einkaufen.
Und der Preis der Zertifikate
richtet sich nach dem Markt,
also nach Angebot und Nachfrage.
Das Gesamt-CO2-Budget
wird mit den Jahren immer kleiner.
Weil wir ja immer mehr Emissionen
einsparen müssen.
Dadurch wird der CO2-Preis
immer höher, die Anreize,
Emissionen zu sparen,
werden also immer stärker.
2) CO2-Steuer oder CO2-Abgabe
Bei dieser Methode
wird von der Regierung
nicht das Gesamtbudget festgelegt,
sondern ein Preis für CO2.
Also ein Preis pro Tonne CO2.
Man nimmt nämlich schlicht
und einfach Kohle, Öl und Gas,
von Kohle, Öl und Gas kennt man
sehr genau den CO2-Gehalt.
Wenn wir Öl z.B. importieren, würde
man hier einfach eine Steuer erheben.
Steuer und Emissionshandel
wirken auf eine ganz ähnliche Weise.
Am Ende müssen wir,
die Konsumenten, bezahlen.
Wenn für ein Unternehmen
CO2-Ausstoß teurer wird,
werden natürlich auch die Produkte
teurer, die so entstehen.
Je nach Produkt
wird dieser CO2-Aufpreis
nicht unbedingt
stark ins Gewicht fallen.
Der Preis irgendeines Produktes
setzt sich ja aus
verschiedensten Aspekten zusammen.
Nicht selten zahlen wir
einen Aufpreis allein für ein Logo
oder eine Marke:
Bei so einem off-white T-Shirt
macht ein CO2-Preis
auch keinen Unterschied mehr.
Aber bei Produkten
wie Benzin oder Heizöl schon.
Das ist auch der springende Punkt,
nämlich dass CO2-Ausstoß
immer teurer und unattraktiver wird.
Das Ganze ist also ein
marktwirtschaftlicher Lösungsansatz.
Bevor wir gleich noch
genauer drauf eingehen,
was das Ganze
für uns Verbraucher bedeutet,
gibt es noch eine Sache, die manche
gar nicht auf dem Schirm haben:
Wir haben in manchen Bereichen
bereits eine CO2-Bepreisung.
Allerdings nur
in den Sektoren Stromerzeugung
und energieintensive Industrien.
Z.B. die Produktion
von Eisen, Zement und Papier.
Und seit 2012
auch für den Luftverkehr.
Diese Sektoren machen zusammen
etwa 45% der EU-weiten
CO2-Emissionen aus.
Bei der Stromerzeugung
hat sich EU-weit und auch bei uns
in Deutschland schon einiges getan.
Der Anteil erneuerbarer Energien
ist auf 40% gestiegen.
Doch das reicht bei weitem nicht,
wenn wir unsere Klimaziele
für 2030 erreichen wollen.
Die Ziele für 2020
werden wir sicher verfehlen.
Beim bisherigen
EU-Emissionshandel waren:
1) die effektiven CO2-Preise
lange viel zu niedrig,
um irgendeinen Effekt zu haben.
Und 2) fehlen bei der CO2-Bepreisung
bisher ganz wichtige Sektoren.
U.a. Verkehr und Gebäude,
also hauptsächlich Heizung.
D.h. bei der aktuellen Debatte
um die CO2-Bepreisung
geht es nicht etwa
um ein völlig neues Konzept,
sondern eigentlich nur
um eine Ausweitung
der derzeitigen CO2-Bepreisung.
Die Forderung,
wir brauchen eine CO2-Bepreisung,
heißt also gleichzeitig:
Und wie man das geschickt und
besonders schnell und gut hinbekommt,
also über einen erweiterten
Emissionshandel oder CO2-Steuer,
darüber wird noch diskutiert, da gibt
es verschiedene Vor- und Nachteile.
Wenn die euch interessieren,
haben wir weitere Infos
in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Im Augenblick z.B.
in Deutschland in der Diskussion
gibt es viele Menschen,
die in der Regierungskoalition sagen,
wir wollen keine Steuererhöhungen,
darum ist uns
ein Emissionshandel lieber.
Wobei man nicht vergessen darf:
Steuer und Emissionshandel
wirken auf eine ganz ähnliche Weise.
Wir haben in einem großen Gutachten
für die Bundesregierung gesagt,
man kann beides machen,
Emissionshandel und Steuer.
Es ist richtig, dass die Steuer
vielleicht schneller geht.
Aber man kann auch den
Emissionshandel so ausgestalten,
dass das sehr schnell gehen kann.
Das sind viele technische Details,
aber ich glaube nicht,
dass man wegen Steuer
oder Emissionshandel
einen Glaubenskrieg führen sollte,
sondern man sollte sich da
pragmatisch verhalten.
Na gut, aber wir, die Verbraucher und
Bürger, fragen uns jetzt natürlich:
Klar, der Grundgedanke ist natürlich:
Wer einen Schaden anrichtet,
der muss dafür zahlen.
Das ist so ein fundamentales Prinzip
in allen Kulturen.
Das Problem:
Obwohl sie im Schnitt
klimafreundlicher leben.
Wenn ich als Niedrigverdiener,
z.B. als ungelernte Kassiererin
in einem Supermarkt,
in einer sehr kleinen Wohnung lebe
und ein kleines Auto fahre
oder gar kein Auto habe,
dann verbrauche ich zwar
absolut gesehen wenig Energie,
und trotzdem nimmt diese Energie
einen relativ großen Anteil
meines Gehalts ein.
Nämlich im Schnitt über 4%.
Auf der anderen Seite
hat die regionale Verkaufsleiterin
derselben Supermarktkette
ein fettes Haus,
einen fetten Schlitten,
gehört zu den Top-Verdienern,
gibt aber nur rund 2,5%
ihres Gehaltes für Energie aus.
Hinzu kommt, wenn ich genug verdiene,
kann ich in ein effizienteres Auto
oder in eine besser wärmegedämmte
Wohnung investieren,
um dann so wieder CO2-Kosten
zu sparen.
Aber dieses Upgrade muss ich mir
auch erst mal leisten können.
Das ist ein Luxus,
den natürlich nicht jeder hat.
Wenn man gerade so über die Runden
kommt, ist es nur verständlich,
wenn man eine Erhöhung
von Lebenshaltungskosten
ziemlich Scheiße findet.
Das bekam Frankreichs Regierung
zu spüren,
als sie eine CO2-Steuer
für fossile Energieträger einführte.
Mit einer Steuer,
die an der Zapfsäule wirkt,
hat in Frankreich der Präsident
seine Bürger gegen sich aufgebracht.
In Paris demonstrieren heute wieder
Anhänger der
Protestbewegung Gelbwesten.
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt und
das ist meine erste Demonstration,
alles ist gestiegen, die Preise
für Benzin, für Gas, für Strom.
Mir fehlen im Monat 200 Euro,
aber meine Rente
ist nur um 3 Euro gestiegen.
Wo soll das hingehen?
Ich habe 42 Jahre lang gearbeitet.
Am Ende des Monats reicht
das Geld nicht.
Wir kriegen unsere Kinder nicht
mehr satt. Finden Sie das normal?
Und hier kommen wir
zum zweiten Punkt,
über den sich die wissenschaftlichen
Experten einig sind.
Jetzt gut zuhören!
Zum Glück gibt es auch Möglichkeiten,
die gerecht zu gestalten.
Das ist übrigens Klaus
vom Kanal "Joul" für
Energiewende und Nachhaltigkeit.
Er macht extrem coole Videos
zu Energiewende und Nachhaltigkeit
und hat sich mit dem Thema
schon beschäftigt.
Die erste Möglichkeit
wäre eine Art Klimadividende.
So macht das die Schweiz z.B.
mit ihrer Lenkungsabgabe
auf Brennstoffe.
Eine normale Steuer
landet ja einfach nur beim Staat.
Aber in diesem Fall darf der Staat
das Geld nicht einfach behalten,
sondern muss es an alle Bürger
gleichmäßig wieder auszahlen.
Wie eine Dividende eben, jeder
bekommt den gleichen Betrag zurück.
Wichtig an der Sache ist, dass man,
wenn man das zurückerstattet
an die Haushalte,
muss man das einfach machen, das geht
nur durch eine einfache Regel.
Wenn man also prüfen müsste, ob
die Bedürftigkeit gewährleistet ist,
wird das ein bürokratisches Monster.
Deswegen haben wir vorgeschlagen,
man nimmt einfach die Gesamtsumme,
teilt die durch die Anzahl der Bürger
und gibt jedem pro Kopf
den gleichen Anteil.
Ihr könnt euch das
ungefähr so vorstellen:
Jeder von uns verursacht
unterschiedlich viel CO2 im Jahr.
Im Durchschnitt sind wir in
Deutschland bei um die 10 t/Kopf.
Das bedeutet,
jeder bekäme erst mal den Preis
für diese 10 t CO2 im Jahr zurück.
Wer selbst mehr ausstößt, indem er
ein besonders dickes Auto fährt,
besonders oft fliegt usw.,
zahlt natürlich mehr drauf
als er zurückbekommt.
Ganz nach dem Verursacherprinzip,
ist ja irgendwie Sinn der Sache.
Wer dagegen aber
besonders klimafreundlich lebt,
kommt in der Regel
bei einem Plus raus.
Denn: Viel weniger bezahlt,
bekommt aber genauso viel zurück
wie alle anderen.
So eine Klimadividende hätte
ein paar interessante Effekte.
Gerade einkommensschwache Haushalte
würden im Normalfall
als Gewinner dastehen.
Eben weil sie
durch ihren sparsamen Lebensstil
relativ wenig CO2 verursachen.
Dann gäbe es einen finanziellen
Anreiz, klimafreundlich zu leben.
Wie geil ist das denn?
Bisher war das oft teurer.
Und drittens: Wenn es sich lohnt,
unter dem Durchschnitt zu liegen,
dann sinkt auf Dauer
der Durchschnitt selbst.
Das finde ich schon faszinierend.
In beiden Fällen werden
die Einnahmen wieder zurückgezahlt.
Im einen Fall
wären es Steuereinnahmen,
im anderen Fall
sind es Versteigerungserlöse.
Es ist eigentlich im Kern
immer der gleiche Mechanismus.
Eine andere Möglichkeit anstatt
einer Auszahlung, wäre es einfach,
andere Steuern zu senken,
so wird es z.B. in Schweden gemacht.
Bei uns könnte man
die Stromsteuer senken.
Warum die Stromsteuer?
Weil die einkommensschwachen
Haushalte
überproportional
viel für Strom ausgeben.
Wenn sie dann entlastet werden,
kann man den sozial ungerechten
Effekt des CO2-Preises kompensieren.
Ich sag mal, generell Steuern
auf klimafreundliche Alternativen
wie Bahnfahren z.B.
Auch damit würde man insbesondere
Niedrigverdiener entlasten,
weil die einen größeren Anteil
ihres Gehalts für Strom, Wärme,
Mobilität ausgeben.
Man wird nie ausschließen können,
dass es Härtefälle gibt.
Man muss
mit solchen Härtefällen umgehen.
Deswegen haben wir vorgeschlagen,
dass man einen Härtefall-Fonds
einrichtet, um Leute,
die auf dem Land leben, überhaupt
keine Infrastruktur haben usw.,
dass die entlastet werden.
Zusammengefasst: Eine CO2-Bepreisung
kann durchaus
sozial gerecht kompensiert werden,
insofern ist das Wort CO2-Steuer
auch gar nicht unbedingt passend,
wenn diese Steuer
an eine Klimadividende geknüpft ist.
Doch da gibt es immer noch
Gegenwind aus der Industrie,
auch von manchen Politikern,
die sagen, das kostet Arbeitsplätze,
das schadet der Wirtschaft,
lieber nicht einführen,
sondern stattdessen
nur auf neue Technologien setzen.
Doch die Wissenschaft
sagt was anderes.
Jetzt gut zuhören!
Wir wissen,
dass der ungebremste Klimawandel
höhere ökonomische Schäden anrichtet
als das, was wir heute
an Kosten aufwenden müssen,
um die Emissionen zu reduzieren.
Vor dem Hintergrund ist
Klimapolitik ökonomisch sinnvoll,
weil die Schäden
in der Zukunft höher sind.
Aber was, wenn Deutschland
jetzt brav Emissionen spart,
während andere Länder einfach
fröhlich weiter CO2 ausstoßen?
Die Angst vor solchen
Trittbrettfahrern kann dazu führen,
dass niemand was machen möchte.
Dieses Problem
haben wir schon im Video
über Spieltheorie besprochen.
Klar, das ist
eine Riesen-Herausforderung.
Klimaschutz funktioniert nur global.
Eine Gefahr,
die die Wirtschaft sieht,
das ganze Unternehmen
abwandern in andere Länder,
weil wir Klimapolitik betreiben
und andere nicht.
Die Gefahr kann man nur bannen,
wenn man CO2-Preise
in allen Ländern einführt.
Daher fliegt Merkel am 21.9. auch
zum UN-Klimagipfel in New York.
Ihr wisst schon, deshalb auch der
ganze Segeltörn von Greta Thunberg.
Unsere Geschichte
hat bisher mehrfach gezeigt,
dass es möglich ist, solche Tritt-
brettfahrer-Fallen zu überwinden.
Z.B. der erfolgreiche
weltweite Ausstieg
aus den Fluorchlorkohlenwasser-
stoffen, Ursache für das Ozonloch.
Außerdem, wenn andere Länder besser
darin sind, Anreize zu schaffen,
um zukünftige emissionsärmere
Technologien zu entwickeln,
dann werden diese Länder
den Zukunftsmarkt dominieren.
Heißt das jetzt, eine CO2-Bepreisung
ist die Lösung gegen den Klimawandel?
Die Wissenschaft sagt nein.
- Jetzt gut zuhören!
Das ist ja klar,
wenn ich CO2 sparen möchte,
muss ich CO2-ärmere Alternativen
zur Verfügung haben.
Wenn ich z.B. öfter Fahrrad
statt Auto fahren möchte,
dann brauche ich auch
eine entsprechende Verkehrsführung,
mit der ich von A nach B komme,
ohne mein Leben zu riskieren.
Nur mal als Beispiel: In Essen
fahren die Leute immer mehr Fahrrad.
Aber es steigt
die Zahl der Fahrradunfälle.
Wenn Sie den Radfahrverkehr
tatsächlich mehr
auf die Straße bringen wollen,
brauchen Sie auch entsprechend
mehr Verkehrsraum dafür.
Das kann ja nicht sein, dass
bei den wenigen Verkehrsflächen,
die dafür zur Verfügung stehen,
sich hinterher
der ganze Radfahrverkehr knubbelt,
und ab und zu fährt da mal ein Auto
entlang, aber auf drei Spuren,
die dafür noch ausgebaut sind,
um das mal extrem zu sagen.
Es muss umgedacht werden,
es müssen mehr Verkehrsräume
dem Radfahrer
zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Oder klar, wenn ich öfter
den Bus nehmen möchte,
muss ich erst mal
einen Bus in der Nähe haben,
der mich dahin bringt,
wo ich hin möchte.
Emissionsarme Alternativen schaffen
muss also aktiv gefördert werden.
Da reicht der CO2-Preis
alleine noch nicht.
Wir brauchen Investitionen
und Subventionen in Bereichen
wie öffentlicher Nahverkehr
oder Wärmenetze.
Wir brauchen auch ganz neue
technologische Innovationen,
revolutionäre Ideen wie z.B.
eine klimaneutrale Stahlerzeugung.
Für solche enormen Sprünge
muss Forschung und Entwicklung
ordentlich gefördert werden.
Aber fallt nicht drauf ein,
wenn Leute behaupten,
dass Forschung und Innovation
uns alle retten werden.
Nein, Forschung und Innovation
alleine reichen genauso wenig aus
wie die CO2-Bepreisung alleine.
Weil wir zwar mit effizienteren Autos
fahren, aber wir fahren auch mehr.
Die Wohnungen sind besser gedämmt,
aber wir haben größere Wohnungen.
D.h., der wissenschaftliche Rat
der Experten an die Politik ist:
Dann gibt es
natürlich auch manchmal Bereiche,
wo Konsumenten
in ihren Kaufentscheidungen
nicht ganz rational sind, z.B.
wenn jemand ein Auto kauft,
rechnet er nicht sofort:
Wie viel ist meine CO2-Ersparnis?
Da kann es dann sehr sinnvoll sein,
dass man
mit Technologiestandards arbeitet.
Und bei noch etwas
sind sich die Experten einig,
und das ist jetzt sehr wichtig.
- Jetzt gut zuhören!
Ohne diese politischen Maßnahmen,
ohne diese großen
kollektiven Veränderungen ist alles,
was wir als Einzelperson machen,
Radfahren, weniger Fleisch essen,
wie auch immer, alles nur Pillepalle.
Wenn das alles auf die Individuen,
auf uns einzelne abgelagert wird,
abgewälzt wird, passiert das,
was wir eh schon wissen.
Einige werden was tun,
andere werden nichts tun.
Deswegen ist ein CO2-Preis wichtig,
weil erst durch den CO2-Preis
addieren sich die individuellen
Anstrengungen aller auf.
Aber heißt das jetzt, dass ich als
Einzelperson gar nichts tun kann?
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil.
Kapitel 2:
Es gibt zwei sehr wichtige Dinge,
die jeder einzelne von uns tun kann
oder sogar tun muss.
Die Klimadebatte ist verpestet
durch unlogische Scheinargumente,
die sowohl uns als auch die Politiker
davon abhalten, sinnvoll zu handeln.
Ein häufiges Problem
ist so was hier.
Das sind alles Argumente,
die verhindern sollen,
dass Politiker jetzt endlich
ihre Verantwortung wahrnehmen.
Dieses "Argument", dieses
Scheinargument ist nichts weiter,
als ein ad-hominem-Argument,
das hatten wir auch hier schon mal.
Es sollte keinen Unterschied machen,
ob ein Argument auf einem neutralen
Blatt Papier geschrieben steht
oder ob eine Person
dieses Argument vorträgt.
"Ad hominem",
kurz für argumentum ad hominem,
bezieht sich auf ein Argument,
das sich nicht auf den Streitpunkt
bezieht, sondern auf die Person,
mit der ich streite.
Du brauchst mir gar nichts zu
den Risiken von Alkohol erzählen,
so viel wie du säufst.
Ein Argument gegen Alkohol sollte
unabhängig sein von der Person,
die dieses Moment vorträgt.
Und wie sehr solche Argumente
gerade bei Umweltdebatten Schaden,
sehen wir
an diesem einfachen Beispiel.
Fall A: Sagen wir,
hier vorne in der ersten Reihe,
der gerade mit dem Handy spielt,
du heißt jetzt Kevin.
Er hat Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen
und als man ihn danach fragt,
sagt er: Nö, hab ich nicht gemacht.
Fall B: Da haben wir Klaus,
du heißt doch bestimmt Klaus, oder?
Er hat auch Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen.
Dabei verkündet Klaus
regelmäßig und öffentlich,
Umweltschutz sei das Allerwichtigste.
Was findet ihr jetzt schlimmer?
Kevin, den Lügner,
oder Klaus, den Heuchler?
Die Mehrheit der Menschen
findet Fall B schlimmer als Fall A.
Wir hassen Heuchler, wir verachten
Heuchler mehr als Lügner.
Ich rege mich nicht dermaßen auf
für den Wald oder die Umwelt,
ich rege mich v.a. darüber auf,
dass dieser Pisser sich besser
darstellt, als er eigentlich ist.
Während ich mich hier so lang
und breit darüber aufrege,
liegt der Plastikmüll im Wald
und niemanden interessiert es.
Dass der Plastikmüll
wirklich niemanden interessiert,
das sehen wir an Fall C.
Da haben wir hier Jerome.
Jerome hat auch Plastikmüll
in den Wald geschmissen.
Als man Jerome fragt, sagt er:
Ja, hab ich gemacht.
Ich stehe dazu,
ich hab's nicht so mit der Umwelt.
Und wie finden wir Jerome?
Ganz okay, oder?
Wenigstens ist er ehrlich.
Natürlich ist er ehrlich,
aber Leute,
das ist dem Wald doch scheißegal,
ob Jerome ehrlich ist oder nicht.
Fakt ist, da liegt Müll.
Wenn wir immer nur
an uns selbst denken,
finden wir den Heuchler
am Schlimmsten,
dann kommt der Lügner und
dann kommt der ehrliche Übeltäter.
Wenn wir wirklich
an den Wald denken würden,
müssten wir es genau andersrum sehen.
Wir sagen, Klaus, das nervt,
dass du so ein Heuchler bist.
Aber wenigstens macht sich Klaus
prinzipiell für Umweltschutz laut.
Kevin, das ist zwar jetzt uncool,
dass du lügst.
Aber wenigstens
scheint Kevin zu wissen,
dass er was falsch gemacht hat.
Und Jerome hier,
der einfach offen und ehrlich zugibt,
auf den Wald zu scheißen,
zu dem müssten wir eigentlich sagen:
Fuck you, Jerome!
Scheinargumente
wie ad-hominem-Argumente
sind nichts als sinnlose Ablenkung
vom eigentlichen Problem
und werden nicht selten von Leuten,
denen das Klima egal ist,
oder die die Wissenschaft verweigern,
ganz bewusst eingesetzt,
um abzulenken.
Fallt nicht drauf rein,
macht nicht mit,
lasst uns bitte aufhören
mit diesem unlogischen Scheiß.
Es gibt immer mehr Menschen, die
zeigen, dass ihnen Nachhaltigkeit
und Umweltschutz wichtig ist, sei es,
indem sie es als Influencer vorleben.
Oder indem sie bei Fridays for Future
auf die Straße gehen.
Und ich sag euch,
das ist verdammt einflussreich.
Denn die wenigsten Politiker
werden eine Entscheidung treffen,
von der sie glauben, dass sie
bei ihren Wählern unbeliebt ist.
Politiker leben von Akzeptanz,
ihre Karrieren
sind von Beliebtheit abhängig.
Wenn Politiker sehen, dass Menschen
freiwillig auf ihre Autos verzichten,
weniger Fleisch essen, Bäume pflanzen
oder über den Atlantik segeln,
dann stärkt das klimafreundlichen
Politikern den Rücken
und setzt gleichzeitig
diejenigen unter Druck,
die vor den Warnungen der Forscher
Augen und Ohren verschließen.
Fridays for Future
hat enorm viel bewegt.
Noch vor einem Jahr, als ich
über CO2-Preise geredet habe,
haben alle gesagt:
Oh, CO2-Preise, das geht nicht,
da kommen dann die Gelbwesten,
die es in Frankreich gibt,
auch in Deutschland.
Durch Fridays for Future sind die
Parteien aufgewacht, alle Parteien.
V.a. auch die Regierungsparteien,
die sagen, wir müssen was tun.
Wir verstehen jetzt, dass junge Leute
sich das nicht mehr bieten lassen,
dass die Klimapolitik
einfach verschleppt wird.
Gleichzeitig bewirkt
jede öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit
von Klimawandelleugnern
und Wissenschaftsverweigerern
natürlich genau das Gegenteil.
Und obwohl diese Gruppe von Menschen
eigentlich ziemlich klein ist,
sind sie leider extrem gut darin,
sehr laut und sichtbar zu sein.
Aber die Vernunft
hat auch eine Stimme.
Und zwar eine viel größere.
Und die versammelt sich am Freitag,
den 20.9., auf den Straßen.
Deshalb, Freunde der Sonne
und dieses Planeten,
schaut bitte
in die Videobeschreibung.
Der erste Link, den ihr dort findet,
zeigt euch die Klimademos in
eurer Nähe. Jeder von uns zählt!
Dieses Video
ist unser 500.000-Abo-Special.
Wir wollten irgendwas Besonderes
zu diesem Anlass machen
und das hier ist es geworden.
Eine halbe Million ist voll
die unbegreifliche Zahl.
Ich kann nur vielen Dank sagen
und viele Kekse rausgeben an alle,
die zuschauen und
die wissenschaftlichen Spirit leben.
Hier kommt ihr
zu unseren bisherigen Abo-Specials.
Besonders kann ich natürlich
unser 10.000-Abo-Special empfehlen.
Und hier
kommt ihr zum Kanal von Klaus
mit den Themen Energiewende,
Nachhaltigkeit.
Er macht so geile Videos,
er hat viel mehr Abos verdient.
Und Kekse, also schaut da mal vorbei.
Wir sehen uns, bleibt sicher!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2019)